well my talk of the table i like this
one too it's about a new young adult
novel that is showing the power of
positivity
even in the darkest of times it's called
punching the air
tells a story of 16-year-old amal who is
imprisoned for a racially charged crime
that
he did not commit the book is co-written
by yusuf salaam who's a member of the
exonerated five
formerly known as the central park five
but now they are known as the exonerated
five
back in 1989 you know the story five
black and latino teens were wrongly
accused of the rape of a jogger in the
new york central park
in 2002 the convictions were overturned
and their story was later turned into
ava duvernay's acclaimed miniseries it
was called when they see us
yusof salaam joins us now along with the
co-author who's got one the best names
eb zaboy they're both joining us this
morning it's good to see you both now i
know that this story
is inspired by your story yusof it's not
your story but it's inspired by it
but yet there are some similarities for
instance both the characters
you and amal used poetry and art to help
you get through
how did that work for you and for him
oh it's true yeah it was definitely
tremendous you know one thing about
art and poetry especially when you just
allow your mind to wander
it allows you to tell the story that you
really need to tell
through the graphics through the poetry
through the essence of what you're truly
trying to get out
it was important to you i hear that you
wanted young readers in particular
you're trying to reach
young readers young black readers why
well i feel like when we want to
do our best and do our due diligence in
terms of our platform whenever we have a
platform we have to make sure that we
speak truth to power and as much as we
can we need to water the seeds of
greatness inside of the future to make
sure that it's alive and well
and to give them a book like punching
the air is so powerful because it tells
people
that there is hope in every place
especially in the most downtrodden
places in the in the world
and we can be the answers to the
question that we seek phoebe what does
punching the air mean
well punching the air can be both an act
of frustration
punching something that you can't see
but it's definitely there
and it can be victorious as you're
punching towards the sky that you've
defeated something great so it was a
perfect title for this book
yeah i hadn't thought of punching there
as being something victorious i also
like
the writing device you use because it's
a novel told in poetry
i think you call it written in verse how
did you two decide that that was the
device
a novel inverse how did you two decide
that that's how you wanted to tell this
particular story this way
well the foundation was already there
when i ran into yousef
evie you you start and then yourself you
pick it up go ahead
when i ran into youssef three years ago
he was selling his self-published book
of poetry that
he had written while incarcerated so the
foundation was already there
um i took one of the most powerful poems
that he had written and built the novel
around that
what were you going to say usa
yeah i was going to say that the great
thing about poetry especially written
this way is that it pulls the
reader through and allows them it keeps
their mind attentive
the words on the page everything is
beautiful about the book punching the
air
this piece that we created is really
really amazing
and you know to do it in poetic format
you know
life is poetry you know that's one of
the best things that we could do
evie i think it's i'm curious about how
the two of you got together because i
know you met in college
and he he at the time was out of prison
but he had not yet been exotic
not yet been exonerated right
yeah absolutely we met at new york
city's hunter college
and uh we always knew that there was
something not right about the case we
knew
that they were innocent and at the time
i was the editor of my college's
newspaper
and i remember the story from when i was
in sixth grade
and when i saw him i just had to get an
interview i never got that interview but
i ran into him again three years ago
and here we are with his novel were you
afraid you have to tell your story
you know when i came home from prison i
was hiding in plain sight
you know here i am over six feet tall
and i had this indelible scar that the
system had labeled me a rapist and i was
very very scared
of who to tell you know my truth to and
you know because it wasn't popular you
know donald trump had taken out that
full page ad
i remember years ago that was 31 years
ago and
i mean i was walking around with that
target on my back at all times
and you talk about the importance and so
does the mall
it's okay to be angry but not be bitter
how were you able to get to that place
and do that well i tell you we you know
i listened to the words of
you know mandiba um nelson mandela and
what he said was he had to leave anger
and bitterness in the prison
because if he took it outside with him
it would destroy him right and then i
heard the words of dr maya angelou who
said
you should be angry but you must not be
bitter and then she taught us how to
you know take that anger and turn it
into something by saying you know
it it can metastasize into something but
if you
use that anger and dance it and write it
and
be you know do everything about it talk
about it talk it never stop talking it
you get the opportunity to take the
the horns of the bull and really direct
it in a manner that really can change
lives i'm wondering if this was a
personal story for you in some way you
said you
i just heard you say you knew this story
as a little girl then you meet him in
college and then you end up
working with them on working with him on
this book
was it personal for you
eb eb
eb can you hear me eb can you hear me
you lost her i think we lost eb this is
what happens in live tv
you can't hear me well i'll tell you
okay go ahead go ahead you know part of
the
yeah part of the conversation that eb
and i had which was really important i
think
because here i am thinking that i'm
going through this in a vacuum that this
is only happening to me
and meeting evie and having the
conversation with her about all of these
injustices that were going on you know
you had amadou diallo
sean bell you had i mean even now we
have so many names that are coming up to
our doorstep
today that it was amazing that she was
able
to realize wow you know he looks like a
boy in my classroom
yeah and that's the connecting that she
was making that all of like all of us
all of the five of us
look like people and were people we
represented the microcosm of the
macrocosm of people just like us
all right yusof salaam thank you so much
for joining us eb saboy
teller we said thank you too the name of
the book is called punching the air
it goes on sale tomorrow wherever you
like to buy your books